[Applaudissements]
ce jingle je vous racontais afrique à un
jour ça me rappelle quelque chose que la
fesse l'a fait c'est un endroit très
très sensible je vous jure que c'est
vrai et j'étais donc animateur dans un
club de vacances et une époque et j
avais fait un sketch sur à ce que vous
rappelez de la pub mais rios en ayant le
mérite de ne pas tolérer d'ailleurs en
beauté et donc je faisais donc ils
marchaient sur le mur est bien le truc
est donc j'ai dit voilà je vais refaire
je me mets des pubs et j'allais venir
matelas et donc je monte dans le truc je
montais une échelle je sautais gens
venaient là et un moment j'ai raté le
matelas en breton moi je suis tombé sur
la fesse et j'ai passé toutes les
vacances avec une fesse plus grosse que
los de nadau
mais je voyais en mai des fous rires et
ses dérivés sepa sepa de mythos et
j'avais écoute les batwa et gt gt prof
de tennis donc imaginer toutes les
vacances
j'étais comme ça donc en fait avec la
fesse énorme dans le short et ça c'est
voilà donc et donc je connais ce que
c'est un grosse j'ai fait ma j'ai déjà
eu très très mal aux fesses gilbert
les bobos